taking care of patients and Outback
communities means packing up your
equipment and medicine and hitting the
dusty road we don't sit in our clinic
waiting for sick or dying people to walk
through the door we provide a service
that goes out to the people and when
dealing with Aboriginal patients there
are cultural and language barriers to
overcome many staff like Vicki are on
short-term contracts because very few
people want to work here full time local
men are being trained up to take on some
of the duties life expectancy for an
Aboriginal man is around 67 and 73 for a
woman that's a decade less than the rest
of the Australian population but even
more shocking is the figure for infant
mortality Aboriginal children are twice
as likely to die before their fifth
birthday as other Australian kids the
poor conditions in which they grow up
are a tough start to life few born here
as a kid in a bush camp and you're going
to be pretty tough fish you get up too
it's also a huge challenge to get them
to go to school during the day many roam
the streets when they should be in a
classroom community leaders will do
their bit to enforce the message but
ultimately it's down to parental
discipline this school is an oasis in
the middle of a desert well funded and
better attended than some but you still
have to be a very committed teacher to
want to work here at the end of every
day Kerry Kazmir washes the uniforms of
all her pupils so they can have clean
clothes to wear their academic
achievement might still be will behind
what we would love them to have for
their age but if they feel like they're
part of the mainstream environment that
we have here and they feel like they're
gaining the skills to jump between the
cultures we think that's a great success
lessons are in English but many
Aboriginal leaders say children should
be taught partly in their own languages
Rosalee Kenneth monks is the elected
head of the local council whose area is
bigger than the end
British Isles but with a population of
just 8,000 we want to and will retain
our culture whatever it takes there
needs to be specialized approached to
education and to my group of young
people maintaining their traditions
while trying to integrate into modern
Australia just one of the many
challenges facing Aboriginal children in
Woods Sky News in Australia's Northern
Territory